and started doing forex trading but he's
not making a lot of money what is forex
trading sorry to interrupt
that's alright forex trading is when you
trade you basically it's like you're
betting against the rise and fall of
different currencies
so it's currency trading you're betting
that the dollar will be worth more than
the euro or whatever you know I don't
know the exact what the definition of
forex trading is okay but I'm sure I'm
sorry just [ __ ] it and said it wrong
basically they're there you can buy it
you can buy like options and you you bet
that it's gonna go up or down and then
you get whatever the spread is and
they'll do it on like a fraction so they
end up but you know you can end up
really leveraging what you've got the
problem is you can lose everything
you've got the real problem with the
whole market is that if I'm winning
somebody else is losing so it's kind of
a back and forth it's you know I'm
saying it's not like the stock market in
sports right yeah somebody's winning
somebody's losing exactly so but
Blayne starts doing forex trading so
he's representing some guys he's using
their money he's investing their money
and but he's not making a lot of money
you know he's very charismatic
good-looking guy and very flashy but
he's not making a lot of money and so he
ends up watching the movie the boiler
room hmm and he gets inspired by the
movie the boiler room and basically the
reason the reason I know all up like I
have all the documents right now what he
actually Ted this is what kills me is
that when he was actually interviewed he
actually tells the [ __ ] IRS agent
which investigate he actually tells them
he was inspired by the movie the boiler
room nice the [ __ ] says that's like
saying you know ice it's like how I was
inspired by Goodfellas so he so and the
boiler rooms the movie about it's just
it's just huge fraud right so what he
does is he goes out and he convinces
blame convinces a bunch of his buddies
and front to invest money with them so
give me ten grand
put in the in the in forex and I'll make
you you know you're gonna making you
gotta make eleven twelve thousand
dollars whatever it may be so a couple
guys give them gives five grand ten ran
it starts small but very quickly these
guys are making huge amount of money
back so they turn around and they say
okay I'm gonna go to my sister and talk
to my sister now next thing you know
this guy's putting in 20 grand his
sister's putting in 30 grand is this
guys putting in 10 grand this guy and
one guy put in one say $120,000
Blaine ends up that the the dollar
amount varies but basically the main
number it ends up being between like
half a million to a million dollars he
takes from these guys friends and
friends of friends he ends up convincing
one guy to help make spreadsheets to
track how the money is growing the fact
is the money's not growing at all it's a
Ponzi scheme guys are giving you money
in and then when you ask for your money
back I just give you your money back
plus a little bit of Danny's money so
you think I just made 20 percent Danny
still thinks his money is in the account
Danny's money's not in his account I
spent it on my new Mercedes yeah and
then the next day when Danny says I want
my money back I just take it from Bob I
give Danny's original amount back plus
what Danny earned so you're paying new
investors with old investors money
you're just hoping that all the
investors are not for their money back
at once absolutely because then you go
under well that's what happens with with
Blaine is that eventually he's one
giving too much that the returns are too
high you know he's not he's not he's not
Bernie Madoff yeah who was giving him
too much money Ben right Bernie Madoff
was giving you enough that you're doing
you're doing better than everybody else
but not so much that it's not that it's
not unreasonable
yeah and so he was able to go forever
Blaine's not that sharp blades giving
guys huge returns and so eventually he
can't pay out their returns and one or
two people asked for their money back he
spins them and he spins them and he you
know oh I'm in Europe right now or all
my my my phone it doesn't work I
couldn't return your email Oh didn't you
get the wire didn't you get the why I
got read all the excuses how old is this
how old is he at this point by the way
just early 20s early 20s like yeah
and so yeah so I wrote and I mean you
know anyway he's gotta be smart in the
early twenties didn't even know about
all this type of stuff horse-trading
inches he's sharp he's sharp and
obviously he's ruthless yes oh god
people are pulling money out of there if
he's convincing people to pull money out
of their 401k get 30 grand out of your
401k give me 30 grand I'm gonna have you
forty-five thousand dollars within six
months you never getting your 40 you're
not getting your 30 so this goes on and
on and eventually these guys kind of
start grouping together because they do
know a lot of a lot of one another so
eventually a group of like I think seven
or eight of them get together they track
him down at his house and oh yes the
video of the video you have a video of
it I have a video on my website inside
true-crime which is on youtube and it's
the video one of the guys brings a video
camera and videos them confronting him
and he's all they're like they're trying
they're telling him he's gotta sign this
piece of paper you're gonna this he's
all like well how much time do I have to
get my money back and at one point he
says he's like I don't feel comfortable
with all you guys are pressuring me and
they're like I don't feel comfortable
with you steal it from us it is like our
so he signs and one of the guys the very
end of the video they cut it off one of
the guys is like look if you don't have
the money by like Monday or something
they're like we're gonna come back here
he used to but I'm here I'm gonna come
back here with some other guys that
aren't like these guys you're gonna be
sorry and they cut the video so it's
pretty funny but yet it's on the on the
on the website so okay so and basically
I know about that whole scam because it
was all in the FDLE report which I have
this whole FDLE report but let me keep
let me flip through here just so that I
can keep up with where I'm at he loses
the much so basically these guys end up
they go to his house he doesn't have the
money they say he says he's gonna have
the money he doesn't have the money
right and eventually he just moves picks
up his [ __ ] knee moves and Abel's right
yeah moose exactly so he lose Orlando
moves to Naples where is that what
that's a Melbourne's no Naples Naples is
on this coast in the Gulf Coast okay so
it's probably like two hours south of
st. Pete
so when he's there he meets a guy named
Dave he meets a guy named Damien
Broomfield Damien is kind of a computer
geek and he's working IT for some
company and he meets Damien's girlfriend
knows
Blaine's wife or fiance or whatever yeah
and they end up at a party together and
they start talking he sees that he's
driving a nice new you know Mercedes or
whatever and so they have a little
chitchat and they both kind of fancy
themselves as being you know savvy
business guys and so blatant starts
talking up Damien tells them about how
he's in for axe making a bunch of money
doing really well they had they hit it
off and they decide to go ahead and
start or Damien decides to give him some
money to invest so he gives him like 50
grand to invest
yeah it's 50 grand to invest so he gives
him like 50 grand and blame basically
blows that money and so when Damien
comes back for the money he says he
convinces them listen let's open up a
business together we'll open up a forex
trading company we'll trade Forex it's
like a you know like a hedge fund or
something where you guys all invest and
we'll invest their money so I don't
quite know if Damien at that point knew
his money was gone or if he just kind of
joined him he very quickly realized this
money was gone